here is a simulation created by Khan
Academy user te TF I can assume that's
pronounced dead F and what it allows us
to do is give us an intuition as to why
we divide by n minus 1 when we calculate
our sample variance and why that gives
us an unbiased estimate of population
variance so the way this starts off and
you can I encourage you to go try this
out yourself is that you can construct a
distribution it says build a population
by clicking in the blue area so here
we're actually creating a population so
we're creating them every time I click
it increases the population size so let
me just and I'm just randomly doing this
and I encourage you to go on onto this
onto this scratch pad it's on the Khan
Academy computer science and try to do
it yourself so here we are I can stop at
some point so I've constructed a
population I can throw out some random
points up here so this is our population
and you saw while I was doing that it
was calculating parameters for the
population it was calculating the
population mean at two hundred four
point zero nine and also the population
standard deviation which is derived from
the population variance this is the
square root of the population variance
and it's at sixty three point eight it
was also pop plotting the population
variance down here you see it's 63 point
eight which is the standard deviation
it's a little harder to see but it says
squared this these are these numbers
squared so this is essentially sixty
three point eight is the population at
sixty three point eight squared is the
population variance so that's
interesting by itself but it really
doesn't tell us a lot so far about why
we divide by n minus one and this is the
interesting part we can now start to
take samples and we can decide what
sample size we want to do I'll start
with really small sample so the smallest
possible sample that makes any sense so
I'm going to start with really small
samples and what they're going to do
what the simulation is going to do is
every time I take a sample it's going to
calculate the variance so the numerator
is going to be the sum of each of my
data points in my sample minus my sample
mean and I'm going to square it and then
it's going to divide it by n plus a so
and it's going to vary a is going to
divide it by anywhere between n plus
negatives
so n minus 3 all the way to n plus a and
we're going to do it many many many many
times we're going to essentially take
the mean of those variances for any a
and figure out which gives us the better
at the best estimate so if I just
generate one sample right over there
well we see when we when R we see kind
of this curve when we have high values
of a we are under estimating when we
have lower values of a we are
overestimating the population variance
but that was just for one that was just
for one sample not really that
meaningful it's one sample of size two
let's generate a bunch of samples and
then average them over many of them and
you see when you look at many many many
many many samples something interesting
is happening when you look at the mean
of those samples when you average
together those curves from all of those
samples you see that our best estimate
is when a is pretty close to negative 1
is when this is n plus negative 1 or n
minus 1 anything less than negative 1 if
we did negative n minus 1 point 0 5 or n
minus 1.5 we start overestimating the
variance
anything less than and anything less
than negative 1 so if we start if we
have n plus 0 if we divide by n or if we
have n plus 100 point zero 5 or whatever
it might be we start under estimating we
start under estimating the population
variance and you can do this for samples
of different sizes let me try a sample
size 6 and here you go once again as I
press I'm just keeping generate sample
press down as we generate more and more
and more samples and for all of the A's
we essentially take the average across
those samples for the variance depending
on how we calculate it you'll see that
once again our best estimate is pretty
darn close is pretty darn close to
negative 1 and if you were to try this
if you were to get this to you know
millions of samples generated you will
see that your best estimate is when a is
negative 1 or when you are dividing but
when you have when you're dividing by n
minus 1 so once again thanks T et f2 f2
think about why
we divide by n minus 1